I saw you and I was already a huge fan
from strangers with candy in the Daily
Show but this was in the age before
cellphones so I couldn't get a picture
so I just went hey for now that's a
place Murfreesboro it was I think it was
named by a dying Confederate General as
he barely sat up in bed eating mashed
potatoes
and his grandson was like happy you got
a name the town and he was like well you
can't marry everyone who's nice because
then you'd be married to too many people
that's what I say it's exactly when I
speak at schools they swim on me they
swim in the sea they have mustaches
famous baseball player Blanc hunter oh
my god are you still my mind that's all
we have time my parents are watching
yeah you know I'm always but was raised
to be so nice and when you're when your
job in there in a role or in a sketch is
to be a prick it's so liberating it's
fun it looked like you were having I bet
you had a good time I didn't have to not
say some of the things I think of you
know have you ever thought like idiot at
the end of a sentence but you don't say
it I guess it's right over there who you
are you're hosting satellite this week
for the second second time which is
great I was nervous some people don't
get to come back that's true they do
controversial things like they tear up a
picture of the Pope or they are Robert
Blake and they don't get that they don't
get to be on soon okay I'm gonna be like
a dump how much I like someone that
checks their phone
I can hide it like people go you're thin
but I'm like I know where the fat is
it's hidden in weird pocket where is
your fat specifically well my body's
like the apartment of a drug dealer like
at first you're like there's no cashier
but then you're like tear open the couch
and there's 900,000 okay and one guy
yelled from the back what is the best
heckle I've ever heard in my life
he yelled excuse me sir I think I speak
for everyone here when I say that we
would enjoy silence more than the sound
of your voice I used to do cocaine
that's true me the person you're looking
at I would smell it up into my nose and
I'd get a high from it so I got a call
and I said hello you know and nothing
fancy ordinary hello you are a you're a
sharp dresser I didn't know you went
this casual because I I feel like I'm
you're like business manager you know we
should talk about an estate plan I know
does it work you brought us something
right yes I believe I have a bit of my
the full Hospital for Special Surgery
report on my hip and pelvis yeah yeah
like the picture boys the Pet Shop Boys
I look like the pet shop psychedelic
mushrooms yeah like how many times yeah
you know not recently not in my adult
life no no little Mulaney trip too you
know I haven't done them in the years I
feel like you've done him when I was
about 11 years old I went to a diner
that had a jukebox where for $1 you got
three plays and my friend and I put in
$7 and then we selected 21 plays of Tom
Jones is what's new pussycat
I think it's an encyclopedia and you can
just look up what everyone in your life
thought about you and if there is a
heaven
it's a Wikipedia and you can just change
that and he played what's new pussycat
22 times for 45 minutes blasting over
the school intercom and they had to
cancel school I see expel no he got
suspended for three days and he couldn't
go to prom
[Laughter]